buckle up and prepare to ride the
carousel because we're off to Wisconsin
never been to Wisconsin yes we're back
with an all-new season of American Gods
which pits the old gods versus the new
and I'm here to break down the episodes
and point out some of the cool things
you may have missed along the way so get
in that ice-cream truck and make sure to
subscribe because here we go the first
shot we get overlooks a luxury Golf
Resort in West Virginia called the
blackbriar you can tell by the BMW
license plate expensive golf clubs and
ball Blackfriars a nod to the Greenbrier
resort in Virginia which apparently
hides a secret undercover bunker for
members of Congress to be held in the
event of an apocalypse this hidden base
is supposedly blocked off by a giant
reinforced steel door which hey that
looks like a giant reinforced steel door
in the background old Gregorian chants
play which is quite fitting since as
soon as our rich golfer dude is run over
by technical boy the music changes to
techno it's already a sign that the old
is being crushed by the new literally
judging by the rush technical boy is in
this seems to take place right after the
events of season one in which Odin
declare war on the new gods and for the
first time we see mr. world the leader
of the new gods seemingly afraid that
unless he does something drastic the old
gods could regain their hold technical
boy shows a paper clip to the security
camera which notifies the caretaker to
open the vault the caretaker and mr.
world speak in code with mr. world
responding to the caretakers word of
challenge with burrow climber and yes my
German isn't that great but that's the
German word for paperclip technical boy
is young and rash wanting to take out
the old guys immediately but mr. world
is more patient they need to have a plan
and marshal their forces before they're
to take on the old gods and wipe them
out for good I can't sell war without my
best salesman
you find he's referring to Gillian
Anderson's character media and what
better way to get people to side with
you than some good old-fashioned
propaganda propaganda meanwhile in
Wisconsin shadow Sweeney Laura and
Mister Wednesday are driving to the
meeting of the old gods and Laura looks
a little worse for wear considering
she's been dead for a few days and will
continue to get worse until someone
resurrects her if you remember back in
season one estera said she could but
upon finding out that Laura was killed
by a god
declined you see it's against the rules
for gods to resurrect someone killed by
another god and laura was killed by
sweeney at the request of mr. wednesday
AKA odin they're off to a place called
the house on the rock which is an actual
tourist attraction located in wisconsin
it appears to be Museum because it is
housing antiques it's housing all kinds
of memorabilia and things from a
different era things from another era
sound familiar
it's only fitting that the meeting of
the old gods would take place in a
museum for things long since forgotten
we get our first look at the new and
improved Bilquis who last season made a
deal with technical boy regain her power
in exchange for ratting out the old gods
we're also reunited with Bob the genie
and Salim who has finally tracked him
down after literally being ghosted after
their one-night stand mr. world says he
needs the eyes of Argos in order for him
to track down his enemies the eyes of
Argos referring to the ancient Greek
giant Argos who was said to have many
eyes which followed or watched others
meanwhile at the motel America there is
the brief mention on the TV screen of
the crops being destroyed which astera
the Easter God was responsible for we
also get a glimpse of a spider which we
also see a few moments later outside the
back entrance to the house on the rock
and that spider being mr. Nancy he
informs the group that a Stara won't be
joining them but that's really because
kristen chenoweth didn't sign on for
this season Odin and Laura Schara not so
heart-to-heart mainly because she
doesn't have one and he explains how he
might be able to help her which she
isn't too sure about since it was him in
the first place who killed her
he also quickly mentions how he killed
himself on the tree Yggdrasil which we
also see him
and on his costume later on and for you
mythology buffs at there you probably
already know that the reason he has one
eye is because he plucked one out in
exchange for wisdom and knowledge Selene
tries to convince Bob the genie to
follow his heart but it doesn't exactly
go as planned
once I desire is to do my job mr.
Wednesday also confuses Salim as being
who belong Anat to pre-islamic Arabic
gods talk about embarrassing and look
who else has arrived Bilquis the vagina
Eater
mr. Wednesday tells the gods that they
first must consult the norms the Norse
and Norse mythology female beings who
rule the destiny of gods and men shadow
gets a cryptic fortune which tells him
every ending is a new beginning he has
no lucky numbers and his lucky color is
dead which might actually be a reference
to Laura Wednesday sweet talk Soria one
of three Slavic gods of old who also
happens to share an apartment with
charity bog Wednesday needs them both
especially chair neva who wields a giant
hammer and we've seen what he can do
with that in season one Nancy gives
shadow some [ __ ] sizing him up literally
by remarking on how wide his shoulders
are Bilquis on the other hand is sizing
him up in a different way Laura snags a
coin from the genie but her fortune
comes out blank likely because the dead
have no future
shadow is invited on the carousel the
carousel a symbol of youth which is
ironic since it's what all the old gods
are riding on their way to regain their
foothold in the world they are then
transported to a rocky shore which I
first thought was the same Shore the
Vikings landed on in season one which
would be the Americas but upon further
inspection I actually believe this to be
mid gird one of the nine realms and
Norse mythology especially considering
Bilquis tell shadow this is a memory of
Odin's the king of Norse myth O's inside
this giant Viking meat hall a meeting
takes place between the old gods who are
now in their god-like forms we have
Bilquis al menos ooh may the goddess of
dawn from the Shinto religion of Japan
mr. Nancy who we can see his slave
markings on his back mama G Zira
Chernabog and of course Odin there are
some other gods here that not much is
known about and I think the writers
didn't know
either here in the post-credits you can
see their names listed as unknown God
warrior woman God and even MJ hobo God
which I'm not exactly sure what a hobo
god is but if you know please leave a
comment below
Odin explains that they've been
abandoned and now must join together and
fight the new gods if they're going to
survive mama G seems to be the holdout
complacent with her role in the Americas
so it will probably take something big
for her to commit like the death of a
god perhaps Bilquis explains that she
can help them show how the new gods use
technology to make her stronger perhaps
this can help them regain their foothold
but considering Bilquis is a spy who
knows how that will pan out shadow makes
an impassioned speech and an effort to
convince mama G stating that they need
to remind people of who they are take
the chance to be worthy of their belief
since if they don't take this chance
they're gonna die anyway but then he's
transported back to the motel America
where everyone is celebrating he even
questions whether what happened was real
or not
Wednesday tells him that with his speech
he thinks they're finally winning the
holdouts over which lets us know that
the old gods haven't fully committed yet
but with what's about to happen my guess
next episode they'll all be on board
Bilquis has a weird kissing scene with
Laura but right before we catch a
glimpse of her phone which says her ride
is on the way she knows about what's to
go down and is getting the hell out of
there it's also clear Laura still has
feelings for shadow as she tells Bilquis
that if she hurts him she'll kill her
you know just normal pre kissing talk
and it's also pretty cool that the old
gods are chillin at a motel called motel
America that's filled with knickknacks
like tiny statues of Liberty at
blackbriar they've tracked down the old
gods and you can even see an aerial shot
of Bilquis making her escape in her
Oberer laura tries to convince shadow
that wednesday is dangerous but for the
first time shadow feels like he's
finally found purpose something to
believe in
sweeney swoops in and tells her shadow
now belongs to wednesday first when
someone takes what's yours
of course he's referring to his gold
coin which now belongs to laura and
which keeps her alive the controller
sends a message from mr. world to mr.
town for a strike package request in the
book mr. town is one of a group of
mister
old's cronies called the spooks they've
been tasked with hunting down shadow and
in the show he's to be portrayed by Dean
winters will likely see him next episode
a sniper then fires into the diner
killing several of the gods in the
process including zoria one of the
bullets even has the Latin phrase Deus
more to autumn which translates to God
is dead
Sweeney finally experiences a bit of
luck when he slips on some blood
narrowly missing a bullet which then
hits Laura in the shoulder but since
she's already dead it's no biggie
shadow takes down the shooter but is
caught by one of technical boys
airplanes / spacecrafts I wonder if mr.
town was the one leading this operation
and that's where shadow is headed we
then say goodbye to zoria who calls mr.
Wednesday a bad good man Sharon a bog
fueled with rage that his rent will now
likely go up curses the people who did
this but what effect that will cause
probably won't be explored the death of
zoria is the most significant part of
this episode as it will likely cause the
gods who were hesitant to join like mama
G to commit to the fight
Laura runs out of the diner and catches
the orange glow of shadow in the air in
the distance
remember after she died in season 1
she's always been able to track shadow
by this glow and this likely means
she'll be used to track him down next
episode but I want to hear what you guys
thought about this episode in the
comments below be sure to thumbs up the
video subscribe as I hope to do weekly
breakdowns for each episode and while
you're at it check out my Twitter at
think's story whitey and until next time
remember daddy loves you very much